To Japanese-Canadians, this park is hallowed ground.
The park was home field to the legendary Asahi baseball team.
During the 1920s and 30s,...
...the Asahi won every championship title in the Pacific Northwest several times over.
The Asahi were a great baseball team, but for Japanese-Canadians they were more than that.
As the most popular team in a city with all Vancouverites,...
...the Asahi filled Japanese-Canadians with pride.
Whenever they took the field,...
...local businesses closed down, and the stands were packed.
Playing for the Asahi became the dream of virtually every Japanese-Canadian boy.
Through the Asahi junior teams, set up to spot young talent,...
...one boy got his dream: Roy Yamamura.